this is a tale of two Stan's yay sorry I
just had to get in the Mabel movie it
really feels like it's been a while oh
my god you know I was just saying to
like better watch 2015 by the way latest
update
it's a key it was it was last time um
yeah actually I feel bad because I don't
worry so so I wanted a different sweater
I waited all this time and I don't get a
different sweater what's the same day
fuck that uh there's two good fittings
by the way so one got me a dipper hat I
was going to wear them and someone also
got you around like Christmastime that
Mabel ah I'm gonna do it yes way I'm
gonna do something with that but not
until we get a different sweater no
literally like we're gonna do it this
morning and then like other stuff came
up and it's like crap well we'll just
have to fit it in where everyone's in
Finland it got compliment yeah well I'll
just go say yeah I put sick as well so
it might be a while before you see
anything on ant-man sorry
I've just been busy with that we got an
interview owns this we got it yeah it's
officer we're just catching up you know
doing this algebraic new pop quiz hot
shots are coming out and stuff like that
so busy with that well also work out
whatever folks
gravity falls a tail to stands uh yes
how share assists against our ripoff my
fairest what a racket
my favorite head oh good thing I saw
them standing race attracted Oh God this
one had so much exposition but so much
comedy at the same time and it's so many
answers that we've been waiting for what
it's always like telling you as we were
watching it I was like I feel like I got
like ten seasons worth of x-files in one
episode and there's still more mystery
yeah I couldn't other shows have done
this I remember a lot being a whole
ostrich after all these shows and it was
so underwhelming in the end because like
we didn't really answer any fitly yeah
there was actually another question no
these are actual answers there's still
other questions that you have before you
have no new questions are raised and
that feels satisfying it doesn't so I
could give it very satisfying other
shows should take notes you know because
it also had the emotional connection the
back story with the twos
fans is actually a really good back
story ah I gotta say my only pet peeve
about the flashback is considering
difference vice I really was like
gunning for like young Stan to still
have the kind of stand boys just to
listen I like I wish yeah I I don't know
like it still doesn't explain Dipper
though I said kid just got extra
testosterone or something what is it his
voice I guess very much very weak
there's no I almost I was when they were
talking to little boy voices I was just
like oh that's weird like a big Josie
the big chin yeah that's like that you
have to recognize them a lot of good
little um background stuff in here to
notice in the opening on the boards when
they're gonna sneak into that little
cave it was a little thing this at
blendin was here yeah I saw that there
is I just just the randomness of their
lies like I'm a big mess of American
gold this Paquet that just took that is
like what uh yo Stan Stan usually says
you know what loves a great Belgian
waffles or something like that it turns
I keep grew up next to a place called
great thumbs in wall yeah um the one
part that for a second
threw me off of like oh my god a new
part of the puzzle and that I realized
when uh when Stanley I guess uh is
leaving I am Lee was in this excelsior
um but but you see the mother come out
with a baby I'm like oh my god they had
their sibling who is that oh yeah
different maples parent yeah I forgot
about that and we never see them side
only well then I know I took well about
it
um the code at the end by the way every
exact wits it was pretty much that the
father didn't know he was going to have
twins so he just named the bull Stan to
make it easy and then somewhere down the
right why just home staffer and Stanley
to tell the part another huge now not a
big one um and yeah the other thing I'll
kind of point out is this is my little
conspiracy theory at the end when he has
the jump drive with all like the
government stuff on it and he gets it to
the goat I think that goat is a
character like I think that's going to
turn out to be a
character that's up to something he's a
government spy I don't know but they
only the goat always has those weird
eyes it's never explained and now it has
all this information that they think
just throw away that's my theory I could
be totally wrong but that's just my
little theory
um but yeah the big thing I liked about
the backstory in this is when you know
they're talking about they're gonna go
on this treasure hunt and but now
Stanford is accepting this College if
the science program goes over well and
you know Stanley is obviously very angry
and I think of myself he's gonna
sabotage the project and I really
fucking hate this but he doesn't do it
on purpose of anything he tries to set
it right but still kind of his fault
because he didn't tell him and he still
sort of messed it up so I like that it's
both a perpetual motion machine it is
one job cannot stop um and but I like
the fact it was been so easy just to
have him like get jealous and do
something but the fact that was an
accident
both adds to it was his fault but
there's still a tragedy to it as well uh
and it's is so his anger still kind of
justified the brothers anger when he
comes back I likes the epic obi-wan
Anakin fight near right before he got
sucked into the game he's like your
mother you did that yourself
this is I just kept it flashing back to
my Star Wars me see to me I got much
more even the way they were fighting you
know the point where he says you know
hey give you know give it back okay
we're like kids yeah they're fighting oh
mama is like your best
yeah but the tattoo on the back is
actually a burn mark we got that now um
yeah so many of the little questions
answered while still we don't know what
exactly is on the other side of gay we
just know that Stan wait what is it now
Stan Lee in stamford yeah but Stan so
which is which says Stanford is the one
that was away Stanley is the one who you
know stabilized you know this yeah oh no
we know that grunkle Stan's twin got
sucked into her and grunkle Stan spent
all this time trying to get him back and
he's not very grateful um but but again
it's even on that thing it's justified
it's understandable because you see you
know what happened
seven times he just totally altered his
life mostly for the worst I was choking
since of his JK Simmons I was like on
the other side of the gate he's like and
that's when I decided become an
airbender in this alternate you baby
distress crossover ever but I was back
with Korra sis alone yeah I'm trailing
what else there's so much shit yeah v um
ah crap I had I stood the son of a bitch
yeah I'm trying to like go through my
own I will say this so uh Stanford who
came back from the game Stanford yeah
yeah Stanford so Stanford says and
that's when I decided to write the
journals I literally went and then those
like shit and then one second later
dipper goes that's why I'm gonna say I
love how this well both it's an avatar
we've just bring it up I have the same
thing in common that they both really
know their fans very well they know
reaction so that they know when you're
going to squeeze and they also know what
you've been writing fanfiction about
conspiracies cuz when Zeus comes up and
he's like you know I'll this better
match my fanfiction is anything that's
hilarious and that's ink that's funny in
the show but it's also funny to walk out
the next 14 hours I've got something
amazing to tell you it's three yeah yeah
so now begins act two
um and you must be some sort of large
gopher is it I get that a lot
is it weird to say I'm actually
surprisingly missing windy wakes your
child up at my anomaly I am I am too we
always kind of said she just heard the
plan girl care would be my rugby yeah
initially I didn't feel she had a whole
lot of character but as the story
progressed the target part was the
romance to it yeah I do
uh what would they add in more of a
character to was you should get a little
more interesting and yeah when they
started to keep her out I'm like yeah
but you're kind of missing her I
wouldn't mind seeing her again um but uh
and of course they're building up
something at the end with like we're
different Mabel are gonna like again to
something fight or they're gonna you
know sort of fall apart or so fami more
than they have in the pan
how do we listen I wanna see that I
think it's like okay I know drama
everything but we are assuming that he
already started it when dipper was
telling able to do one thing and she's
like no I'm sorry I trust you know
grunkle Stan oh you see in that couple
episodes you know the mistrust and
everything was already building well but
that's why it's so interesting that now
could be a layup like something even
bigger sad because it's like they have
done this uh so you know and they've
gotten you know pretty close to really
you know sir hurting their their
relationship so now it's gonna be like
something even bigger than that and this
week because this is the first non kid
centric episode in a long time yeah like
this I'm like really dipper Mabel they
probably had a dozen lines may be all
together throughout this whole show like
this episode most of the jokes are dull
jokes yeah and it's all about um the -
grumbles I guess it's it didn't and
resident who stands um so yeah it was
all about the two stands and really yeah
like I was like very little out of
dipper or maybe like I can't even
remember many of their lines except for
that ah yeah you know and I like that
ask him I really did that soon yeah no I
chew it hold on
no cuz I could see you getting ready to
squeal yeah what he's gonna do at the
same time that dipper does which is very
funny um but yeah I kind of agree that
this was mostly focused on even though
it's about you know their childhoods and
growing up instead of you're right it
was mostly focused on them as adults and
what they had to go through and by the
way but I saw at the comedy - as in the
side we have crazy Midwestern weather
going on so we just had like
thunderstorm and now the Sun just came
out so yeah I'm gonna add exponents why
I mean you're probably gonna well it's
you know it is like God is shining down
on us he is happy with what gravity
falls it area
but yeah that's why I just went my dojo
know what because it is why are we to
God you want to talk to God
let's go I don't fair to do um actually
this is the first time - I believe that
gravity falls was used not as the name
of a vocation but as an explanation of
what will happen when crunket comes out
after wasting his time working on
personal computers in his garage uh when
he comes down below Bill Gates Steve
Jobs not there yeah he's building
computers in this garage in power
placing his time yeah uh when he comes
back he says you know uh something along
the lines of you know when went but
gravity falls all hell will break loose
and stuff like that I mean so it's it's
actually used as a term not as the name
of a location which I thought was very
interesting well the other interesting
thing is as much as he wants to blame
grunkle Stan for all the problems they
both leave this wake of destroyed human
lives yeah he totally ruins mcgucket's
life you know grunkle Stan takes out the
poor woman's eye it's just all of the
explanations like these two are like a
walking disaster what I'm even after all
these years he brings him back and you
know he thinks he's gonna go on and
finally that treasure hunter just
whatever you know something and he's
like take this and get out of here and
never see me again just take away so I
can't find it and they both feed into
each other which i think is very
important um you know I I think sort of
Stanford's inability to forgive and
Stanley you know constantly it sort of
just say Stanley you keep saying Stanley
and I keep le I keep thinking of like
Marvel or something no you say Stanley
they're both Stanley yeah there you said
it right Stanley Stanley say and Stan
leave that's how you keep saying it no
how about you Sam are you gonna
understand me how that's what you did
that's what you did like the first
weston he did it a number of times I
swear over wine and then when you tell
me if I says damn
you keep putting emphasis um Lee never
you mocking when you get there you said
it French we're talking about how
brother cannot forgive each other for
stupid little things and this is in no
way proving my point
you're an idiot um what was the other
thing
oh I like JK Simmons in this role I
think the way they dressed him and the
way he's doing the voice which is kind
of as normal JK Simmons voice but sounds
like Robert Stack like it's got an
unsolved mystery sing going on you're
still just gonna sit here and stand
dude Stan Lee dude I swear I got damn
good you ready dude stupid Pig um ed ago
see if I said it French the conscience
altered an entire day now every life we
go under the comments go be Stanley's
dead
listed at least we're just gonna get a
bunch of French reply yeah gonna be
swearing amen actually Stanley's it less
than ever to keep hitting C translations
fuck you Walker brothers are Stanley
translate Stanley um so uh no this was a
really good episode
I like JK Simmons and I like you know
it's so quite cuz when we think of JK
students we kind of think of one role we
think of spider-man the guy behind the
desk a guy who talks really fast is
really you know what strong and
determine a guy in charge and obviously
when it comes to his voice work he's
actually very versatile yeah well you we
got Cora we got this he's isn't he also
the yellow is the yellow yeah the peanut
M&M so yeah it's funny like I associated
him visually with jonah Jameson from
spider-man
but even then not so much anymore now I
associated with the State Farm guy yeah
yeah Oso sorry was it yeah we are
farmers boom boom um oh I was gonna say
I think it's one of those things where
yeah cuz why I heard he was gonna play
the role like well Ken he's a good actor
I just hope it's not like you know just
get me pictures of spider-man you know
but it's not it was again sorry this new
character I get my I get unsolved
mysteries particularly with the trench
go and everything and the way he talks
it's got this sort of singsong I don't
know something going on in this one
but there's also a little bit one salt
mystery oh yeah there's a bit of a panic
in there yeah I mean you can tell they
sound enough like that you can see them
as brothers yeah um so I'm trying
anything else you think you've got
problems I got a bullet
I got a moment I've been in prison in
three different countries I got you out
of a trunk charge of a lot of great
grunkle Stan lines in this one yeah um
the dog pretty much almost as good as
what did I do it Awards this much
arrested it's a no it's a good episode
it has good con me good exposition but
swear I thought it was worth the wait
um I did can we get a normal schedule
though please what I don't know if it's
and the episodes gonna run like four
weeks from now now we're got about a
two-week hiatus it's gonna be be back
five weeks later and then uh in between
will run episodes of Spongebob and
something on your never call big photos
now and this is the sponge bath Empire
is growing um no I honestly I'll wait
it's oh wait I think that yes I don't I
think the next one's like August or
something now there's like I'll get my
80 I mean it's one of those things where
it's like you know our guy because I
want it but I I love it because they're
always so good at just I don't mind more
Weiland but I would rather wait to see a
block not one episode that's what's
bugging me it's uh but again this
mishmash is just gives you fair accent
I'll be good to be fair if there's an
episode away for this this was a good
episode away for it oh no I'm not saying
it wasn't I'm just like why couldn't you
then just run it in August um I don't
know did we need the snack life is over
um but I'm definitely full from it so we
would say it was a longer neck
nevertheless so uh yeah uh that's about
it
like I said more you know the bummer
view and sibling rivalry of a man
private delayed sorry we'll still have
the new pop quiz hot shot coming out
though and the Nastasha pay will be a
full review next time uh so yeah and the
Steven universe we'll get back to those
so yes all right just Finland got sick
if you can hear him a lot better though
and I'm just catching up so um yeah lots
more stuff is on the way and
more gravity falls will be on us soon
too so until then still ooh good night
stupid good night then stupid